read so i know everybody wants to be on
tv because there's so many media outlets
because they're such a hunger for
conservative content there is an
incentive structure that leads people to
get out there before they are ready it
leads people to get out in the public
eye before they have fully formed
thoughts that's a dangerous thing people
who are experts on a topic are people
who have read 10 books on a topic
people who are qualified to speak on tv
about a topic are people who have read
an article on a topic be the person who
reads 10 books on the topic not the
person who read the article on the topic
and this means listen more than you talk
at least for now